welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as we look ahead to the third
mcu spider-man film its predecessor
spider-man far from home left that door
wide open to the question of peter
parker's suits and gear
as an apparent criminal or at least a
kid accused of being one
we're probably gonna see peter parker
lose his suits
confiscated because as we explored not
long ago in big question
even if peter parker is somehow
exonerated of murder and of war crimes
he still has a pesky little law called
the sokovia accords that are still in
effect
he remains in violation of and if the
government is willing to confiscate
captain america's shield from sam wilson
and give it to one of their guys
i doubt they're gonna let little peter
parker keep his oh
iron spider armor capable of instant
kill or for that matter his far from
home sued his homecoming suit his night
monkey suit or even his underoos
they're gonna make the poor guy go
commando but while re-watching far from
home and seeing
more and more clues coming out of the
next film i noticed some interesting new
details that might give us a clearer
picture of what kinds of threats
peter parker could face in his upcoming
battles let's break down the 10
spider suits and designs that currently
exist in the mcu
at least 10 because if tony stark made
iron man suits he probably had at least
a few dozen spider-man ones by my
account
actually as many as 40 spider-man suits
but i'll explain how i got to that
number
but before we continue this video was
brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing
tools and analytics squarespace
is the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence and to run
your business
okay first peter's original underoos
suit the ben riley s
hoodie getup that peter was seen wearing
in tony's video clips in civil war
and the suit peter reverted to in
homecoming after tony confiscated the
suit he gave peter second
the stark suit worn by peter in civil
war and in homecoming in the beginning
of infinity war and briefly in venice
and far from home third the iron spider
armor from infinity war an endgame a
truly iron man nanotech pressurized
armored suit that's got extendable arms
it's all based somewhat on the red and
gold iron spider suit
in the civil war comics that suit was
last seen recharging in queens most
radioactive utility bill nightmare
fourth the stealth night monkey suit
worn by peter in austria prague in
berlin
and far from home an alternate disguise
given to peter by team fury slash
team mysterio team skrull to be honest
it's kind of hard to know exactly what
that team was anyway this suit was
compromised by mysterio
so that it was putting deceptive
illusions in peter's mind so
peter had to ditch it in holland and
build a new suit bringing us to fifth
the upgraded far
from home suit the suit peter designed
in the stark jet on his way to london
with the darker features in webbing and
he also increased the electric charge
which came in handy later this is the
suit he is currently wearing post end
game so that's five
but when peter built that suit the tech
in stark's lab displayed several
alternate designs going from left to
right there is a sixth armor
looking design that someone described as
the classic 90s spider armor mark 1
the silver one that has shown up in a
bunch of comics and games but
i have actually finally confirmed that
this is a different design altogether i
will come back to this
but the seventh suit design just to the
right on that display is the
superior spider-man suit and you can
tell from the chest emblem this is from
a run in the comics in which
doc ock possesses the body of peter
parker in the middle of course is the
stark homecoming era suit and then to
the right of that is the iron spider but
not the one from the mcu notice that
emblem this is a
separate eighth design the iron spider
from the comics
that tells us that before the iron
spider suit tony offered peter at the
end of homecoming there was an alternate
previous iron spider design that he
decided not to go with
and then on the far right there is a
ninth design that looks very much like
the secret war
suit known for the comics in the ps4
game for its sleek black design with
light blue lines and a thin red web
pattern on the mask arms and boots this
is a suit given to peter by nick fury in
the comics similar to the way fury gives
peter the stealth night monkey suit and
far from home but again thanks to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
are you looking for a website to sell
your wares maybe you're a talented
artist but nobody is seeing your work
because you're just carrying it around
an old steve
rogers portfolio satchel you gotta
present your work to the world using
squarespace's professional portfolio
designs display projects and
customizable galleries and add password
protected pages to share private work
with clients
you can auto post your content to
twitter facebook or tumblr you can also
easily import from instagram
twitter and other platforms to give your
site the personal visual flair you want
squarespace will even sell you a url
somebody go check to see if old stevie
satchel.com is available or maybe don't
that could be something weird head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch
go to our custom url in the description
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain
now there are more designs a few seconds
later on the left in the front is a
tenth design
the spider armor mark ii from the comics
also in the ps4 game
thinner armor with a black and yellow
palette notice the triangular segments
in the emblem but then behind it
is a heavier armor which would be in
11th design but
compare it to the first design we saw on
this holo display design number six
i just realized this is the same one and
based on those heavy shoulders
it is the spider armor mark iii from the
to the ends of the earth comic event in
which peter built this suit with horizon
labs to be able to neutralize the
attacks
of each of the sinister six doc ock
actually ends up hacking it so there you
go that is ten
different spider suits we have seen
visually on screen so even if peter gets
his current suits taken there are always
more backups that he could suit up with
now yes the suit lab on stark's jet was
blown up in the final battle and
avengers hq
was wrecked in end game but tony also
had his own lab
in his separate lakeside farmhouse the
guy probably had gear and weapons rigged
up ready to deploy from remote locations
all over the world
maybe even in a satellite orbiting over
the world and bringing up that infinity
war iron spider suit earlier remember
how
tony summoned it unlock 17a
17a looking closely at avengers hq there
there appear to be about
20 deployment silos and presumably a
and b sides to both so as many as 40
options now maybe some of those are
armor for people other than peter like
tony himself for roadie for pepper but
still
it tells us that these suit design
options are
endless and including designs
specifically linked to certain comics
might tell us how peter will need this
kind of tech in the next film
the iron spider mark iii interests me
because it shows up twice on peter's
display and far from home
suggesting it definitely influenced
peter's custom design as he was heading
into london
and using the mark iii as a reference
point tells me that the filmmaking team
at marvel and sony intend to confront
peter with the threat this armor was
designed to protect against the sinister
six
i have explored the ways this is gonna
play out sony has already established
six or so of the spider-man villains
adrian toombs vulture
michael morbius olivia vampire jamie
foxx electro
venom and or carnage potentially
scorpion and shocker they're still out
there maybe
new figures like doc ock and norman
osborne we know craven the hunter is
going to be his own spin-off movie
but with doctor strange joining peter in
the third film we could see these
villains crossing over from a
multiversal
web of life and destiny think about an
endless fighty villain spot with
endless spidey suit upgrades now do we
need a replay of that house party
protocol scene in iron man 3
maybe not but dozens of suits deploying
to
attach onto dozens of alternate peter
parkers from other
swips in the spider verse that theory is
my kind of house party
oh by the way if you want to support
this channel get some amazing apparel
and accessories for yourself or as a
gift check out our new merch store at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can join this
conversation with us on discord and get
a special patron discount on merch by
becoming a patron of new rockstars at
patreon.com
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars hit
that notification bell follow me at ea
boss follow me rockstars thank you for
watching
[Music]
you